[Music]
joining me this week is an author and
entrepreneur a speaker and a master of
all kinds of cool things some have
called him the Oprah of audio Tim
Ferriss welcome to the Rubin report
thanks for having me the Oprah of audio
how do you like that moniker well it
must be the striking resemblance that we
have I'm flattered by it I think that
couldn't ask for more flattering moniker
although I think it still remains to be
seen if I can live up to that but yeah
it it's been a trip and audio and my
experimental career in audio have you
ever given your audience cars has
everyone got in the car yet I have I've
not done cars yet I've done t-shirts
mushroom coffee and a handful of other
lower ticket items sometimes sardines
canned sardines but not yet cars have
made my way up to the cars yet
yeah sardines very good for you and
we're gonna talk about some of the
things that you've given away and some
of the ideas that you that you push
amongst your crowd I was feeling undue
pressure to ask the right questions this
week I think I'm alright at this but I
thought all right Tim Ferriss fine he's
known as asking good questions so the
first question I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
abroad with you for number one for the
person that's watching this that has no
idea who Tim Ferriss is if that if such
a person exists what would you say is
what is the mission of Tim Ferriss Tim
Ferriss is a self experimenter who runs
experiments with the help of some of the
world's top performers could be
scientists could be athletes could be
entrepreneurs CEOs etc and then writes
about the results so that readers can
have the Cliff Notes version and that is
really the gist about all of my
experiments work out as planned which
make for entertaining reading and tragic
injury on my part in some cases but
generally speaking I view myself as an
experimentalist and a teacher not
primarily writer and it is my job to
push the extremes and do
that heavy lifting so that my my readers
do not have to when did you get
interested in all this was there a point
like when you were in high school or
junior high were you always testing the
limits of what you could do and trying
to figure out what was next in ascent
type I was starting probably around age
13 14 and that was competitive wrestling
I was put into kiddy wrestling when I
was probably 10 by my mom was very
hyperactive and other moms recommended
that as a way to defuse things and drain
my batteries but I was also very very
small I was born premature and I was
very small up until about sixth grade
and in this case you had weight classes
so the 60 pound weaklings could battle
the other 60 pound weaklings and someone
could come out on top and as I moved
further ahead and got better at
wrestling I realized there was a huge
advantage in a recording your workouts
and training approaches be recording the
technical practice and see getting very
good at weight cutting so I actually
become very very good at cutting weight
which I don't recommend it's not a
healthy thing to do because it's
primarily dehydration but yeah I am you
literally would not drink water right
for for it was it just a couple days
before and then right before the match
you'd like down and hold yeah no water
yeah you you dehydrate and then
rehydrate so I would actually cut from
my senior year 178 to 152 is 26 pounds
twice a week and that was done between
12 and 18 hours to do that without
evering it's some type of organ failure
you have to get a good basic
understanding of sodium-potassium how
all these things work together so you
don't really really damage yourself but
I saw the rewards they're from
documentation and experimentation and
then later to start applying that to
everything yeah so in a weird way you
were sort of you were kind of like a
scientist as a kid you were using your
own body as the as the experiment and
you were documenting everything and kind
of seeing what worked yeah that's right
and actually went to high school with
the son of George Plimpton who I only
really came to appreciate later as one
of the first I guess you could call them
fully immersive participatory
journalists who would try to play a
professional football game or box
someone like a Sonny Liston for a few
rounds and then write about leaks
at the experience so this is this is not
a new tradition a lot of people have
done it but I think that I was one of
the first to at least popularized really
taking the physical component to an
extreme degree but although all the
principles can be applied or many of
them can be applied to the world of
business they can be applied to the
world of say educational language
learning the principles are very
flexible yeah so the 4-hour workweek I
think was really the first thing that
put you on the map in in a bigger sense
you know I I saw you a couple of weeks
ago we had dinner I was worried about
you know can I eat carbs in front of him
or whatever you were very non-judgmental
I appreciate that but for me I've been
building this studio for the last month
I have had one of the craziest months in
my 40 years on earth I mean my eating
habits have been terrible I literally
haven't been to the gym in um I just
have not had a moment to get any of that
right so what would you say to somebody
that's really when you're in the thick
of it when life is actually just you're
just thrown in the river and you just
got to go you can't fight the current
and it's for something that you want to
do how would you recommend I manage some
of this this time and stress and all
this stuff well I would think there are
a few different questions that I tend to
depend on in situations like that so for
instance I mean I just I just completed
a 700 page book in less than four months
and that's for me unheard of all of my
book projects have been 3 years and I
think that's what you're working with
yeah the funny it was like forward to
page laid out beautifully yeah and the
the question that I returned too
frequently was what would this look like
if it were easy or what might this look
like if it were easy and brainstorming
seemingly absurd answers to questions
like what if I had to write this book in
a week I knew I wasn't going to attempt
to write in a week but what if I had to
add a gun against my head and you can
you can generate ideas that fall outside
of your current constraints that you've
applied if that makes any sense so in
the case of building a studio in the
case of saying
recording my podcast I very often am
trying to prevent the I think very
natural tendency towards complexity and
sophistication which often times I think
that whether it's building a studio or
writing a book and there are benefits to
this I don't want to discount the value
of what I'm about to say but I remember
when I was writing my second book and I
told an author friend of mine well 90%
done and he goes well congratulations
you only have half left and sometimes it
makes sense to put in that last 10%
other times it makes sense to actually
get started and experiment with
less-than-perfect and that's it's very
context dependent but that those be a
few meta kind of approaches I don't take
and then you you can also apply
certainly things like the 8020 principle
to just about anything so you have
Pareto's law or the 80/20 principle
which you could look at in a few
different ways so one is you could ask
yourself for instance what 20% of the
equipment or activities or
infrastructure gives me 80% of the
output that I want in the case of a
studio right
conversely if you've already been
working on it for say a week and you
have three weeks scheduled left you
could ask yourself what are the 20% of
gear or activities or personnel for that
matter who are causing 80% or more of
the emotions that I do not want and and
that could create a not to do list or a
for now omit list like to be assessed in
the future list so those are some of the
the tools and frameworks that I would
tend to use in a situation like that or
if I'm juggling you know I real sort of
financial careers as a as a tech
investor and I stopped doing that about
a year and a half ago but in fact the
matter is I have portfolio say 70
companies that's a lot to manage in and
of itself so these these are the types
of questions that I will ask myself and
people who are running these SAS chrome
growing companies yeah very often how
hard is it for you to delegate some of
that stuff so 70 tech companies there's
a lot going on it's I would assume
basically virtually impossible to really
know the nitty-gritty of everyone I'm
sure you don't even want to know the
nitty-gritty
every one and some are probably more
passion projects than others how easy is
it for you to delegate some of that and
have a core group of people to trust
that can advise you I is when it comes
to the angel investing I I delegate very
little I I do have a small team who will
work with companies on very specific
aspects of say conversion optimization
or user interface things like that based
on my direction but I've also phased how
I at least historically have done
investments that I only have of those
seventy say five to ten maximum who
actively need my help at any given point
in time and the the one of the signs
that a company is probably going to do
poorly is this if they constantly want
your input
they should be spending a high
percentage of that time having their own
opinions and in building mode and if
they're if they're constantly in a sense
procrastinating doing the work by asking
for advice then you you generally take
that as a red flag because things are
going to go sideways but I tend to face
things that I only have five to ten
active at any given point in time and
then I have a I would say a process that
I impose on each of those initial
interactions so that I'm checking boxes
and those require typically a fair
amount of homework and introspection
on the part of the companies so I'm able
to pace it in that in that respect it's
very rare that I have more than five
companies or five to ten let's say come
to me in a given month with any type of
time-sensitive requirement they're
generally pretty thoughtful about it and
since I'm working in the venture-backed
Decker inna the the best founders and
CEOs understand how to interact with say
a board of directors and they would
treat me not quite as a member of the
board directors certainly but they would
understand how to best utilize my time
because they've done that with board
members already yeah so as a tech guy
how realistic is Silicon Valley the show
oh the show
I think it's spot-on in a lot of ways oh
yeah it's I think I think it is very
accurate in a lot of respects which is
why I find it so funny
especially the second season although a
lot in the first season as well it is it
is uncannily accurate in a lot of
respects and I don't take that as a bad
thing
I mean Silicon Valley is a quirky part
of the world but if it weren't quirky it
wouldn't be what it is it wouldn't be
able I think to produce a lot of what it
produces and it's a weird place it has
its flaws and its foibles but that's
true of any location where you have tend
to have a mano conversation rights if
you go to Washington DC and you have the
mano conversation of government and
politics
it's a weird weird place you go to say
Los Angeles and you have in many places
the mano conversation of entertainment
that's a really weird weird environment
I would argue weirder in some ways since
then Silicon Valley yeah in Silicon
Valley of course it's a tech so you have
just as much weirdness and eccentric
behavior to put it politely as all of
those other places yeah I'm not sure if
you'll know the answer to this but how
mana Thea mano the monotheistic
monolithic how about that yeah not a
theistic would be something else
how monolithic is sort of the political
thing up in Silicon Valley do you think
cuz I you know over the election there
were all these articles written about
Peter Thiel he's the bad boy of Silicon
Valley he doesn't think like everybody
else and it seemed odd to me that they
were like well we can find one guy now I
know he likes putting himself out there
and he obviously he spoke at the RNC and
he's back Trump and all that stuff but
is the is the political group think
they're as strong as as it seems to be I
would say so it's it's very well I may
be I may be getting a little above my
paygrade in terms of subject areas this
is not an area of expertise for me but
there is such an echo chamber I think in
Silicon Valley in many respects or just
in the in the Bay Area that it's easy
for everyone there to pat themselves on
the back in a very aggressive hyper
liberal / progressive way and look down
their nose at what they would perceive
as the rest of them
America and its it's obnoxious and
sanctimonious in a lot of respects and
it's also very very counterproductive so
it's I mean I don't know how far we want
to go down the political rabbit hole we
can do it but I mean there there's part
of me that feels like you know I'm
probably good I'm gonna get myself into
trouble here but it's a spun it's a
smugness that I think is part of the
reason why and this is someone speaking
as I would say you know very socially at
least a liberal person that's smugness
is part of the reason they got their
teeth kicked in yeah and it's just that
they went in really under estimating the
opposition and sort of car plus riding
off everybody who was leaning towards
Trump as stupid or ignorant or racist
even worse or fill in the blank whatever
it might be and that created a huge
blind spot I think Janet might spot and
under estimating the the flaws in
polling methodology I think was also
something that that from a rational
perspective if for instance I mean I
know my brother's is a effectively a PhD
is finishing his dissertation in in
statistics he called Trump months before
it happened really he's oh yeah he's
absolutely gonna win and he is not he
would not position himself as a
conservative and in any respect Scott
Adams you know creator of Dilbert also
on my podcast called it kind of blow for
blow how it was gonna go down yeah yeah
and it's it's III do think that just to
get back to your question that there is
a lot of groupthink in Silicon Valley
and the the irony of that I think is
worth underscoring because it's supposed
to be this think different place and yet
it has all of its own baggage and
groupthink just like every other place
that has a mono conversation and then
you have someone like a Peter Thiel come
along and I've spent time with Peter
he's not a close friend but I've had
dinner you know guy been a group dinners
with him a number of times
and he's a smart guy so the first thing
that I thought to myself when he came
out in support of Trump wasn't how could
he do this it was what am I missing
what am I missing there's something I'm
missing here what am I missing
because Sheila's not I mean certainly in
my experience a very impulsive
short-term thinker that's just not
that's just not him so from the very
outset I was like what am I missing
like is there some 20-year long bed or
short bet that he's making right now
what what aspects of this am I missing
but yes I do think there's a lot of
groupthink in Silicon Valley which is it
just creates blind spots and opens the
door for then not only disruptive
technology to say trying to cut out off
a Yahoo or someone like that at the
knees but it creates I think
vulnerabilities in in a political in a
political landscape and far beyond that
[Music]
you